how do you get the current URL with
JavaScript well there are a few
different things I'm going to show you
if you have this URL HTTP colon slash
slash scars at CC / example / ends X
slash HTML you can do window that
location that protocol and that's going
to give this the HTTP colon you can do
window that location that host and
that's going to give the card CC just
that first part if you do the dot PAP
name you can get everything after the
the host name so the example dot slash
index and if you do we know that
location that H ref you might get the
whole thing besides doing one at that
location that href you can actually
build it manually basically of our new
your URL equals when to that location
that protocol that's this one up here
plus slash less plus one of that
location that host which is the host and
then you just add this last and on the
path name you can also break up a URL
into an array so you can access the
components individually if you have you
are like this where you can see it's J's
nugget / is / awesome slash and next to
HTML you can you can do a split on the
slashes so each items between the
slashes will be its own index in the
array so then you can access different
parts by just exiting path array and
then putting the index of the part of
the array that allows you to manipulate
the the you have the different parts of
the URL and if you want it after
manipulating you can put them all back
together however you want and you can
also get the different parts of a URL
using jQuery so this is the general
thing eight to put of our x equals then
you get the location dot a TDR and then
you're gonna put the property what
what's in here actually changes
depending on what you want Francis if
this is the URL and this is a little
more components on the other example and
then down here if you if you put host
and place of where this property up here
you're gonna get this part if you get
hosting it if you put host name in place
of that property you get this part and
you can see free so you can get the pork
the protocol the path name
gaged ref just gives you the whole thing
except it does not give you the this end
part hash or search will give you
everything after the question mark well
thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good